hey leute vielleicht habt ihr im
internet schon mal ein solches video
gesehen
ein rostiges rohr wird mit einem laser
bestrahlt und scheinbar mühelos
verschwindet der oft ohne dass das
metall darunter schaden nimmt
dino wie viele andere auch hat nicht
dieses phänomen fasziniert wie kann man
mit reinem licht etwas so hartnäckig ist
die rost entfernen und sie funktioniert
es dass dabei wirklich nur die oberste
schicht berührt wird
um das herauszufinden habe ich ein
unternehmen besucht dass genau diese
laser herstellt
[Musik]
das unternehmen heißt clean laser und
besucht habe ich jetzt nicht alleine
sondern im rahmen der photonik akademie
2000 wird finden hier konnten 30
studenten eine woche lang alles über das
arbeiten mit licht und langsam erfahren
am forschungs kampfes bp in aachen und
in vielen unternehmen der branche ging
es um neuartige herstellungsverfahren
die fabrik der zukunft und besonders
spannend den 3d druck mit laser wie
schon im letzten jahr habe ich die
akademie die ganze woche über begleitet
dazu mache jetzt ein video über einen
spannenden themen nämlich wie
funktioniert ein laser der stark genug
ist um rost zu entfernen
alle sind sehr kurze sehr sehr sehr sehr
sehr stark erhitzen
das ist doña aus der applikations
abteilung material geht es direkt von
den festen in den gasförmigen zustand
über das ganze passiert in der
deckschicht die deckschicht absorbiert
in favor die energie des lasers darunter
das material ist sehr glänzen
da wird ein elfer reflektiert und so
kommt es dafür das hat nur die
deckschicht vom laser abgetragen und
verdampft wird und das material darunter
ein weißes blatt ok das waren sehr viele
informationen auf einmal deswegen auch
mal schritt für schritt für alle die
gerade nicht mitgekommen sind
das gerät mit dem sonja hier arbeitet
sie zwar anders aus als die handgeführte
variante funktioniert aber im grunde
genommen genau so das erste was mich
persönlich total überrascht hat ist dass
der rost war don agiert weg schicht
nennt nicht einfach wegschmilzt er
explodiert nicht einmal nein er bekommt
nur viel energie ab dass er direkt
verdampft
um so viel energie zu erzeugen werden
zwei dinge mit dem laser getan
zum einen wird die gesamte energie auf
einen werk sein punkt gebündelt mit
gerade einmal 75 mikrometer die dicke
eines menschlichen haares
und zum anderen wird der laserpuls wir
lassen den laserstrahlen nicht
kontinuierlich auf dem senator sondern
wir wollten ihn wieder laufen nur zum
beispiel 200.000 mal in der sekunde
wer sich zu entladen das heißt die
einzelne entladung hat eine ganze menge
energie infos und das ist wesentlich
mehr manchmal tausendfach mehr als die
durchschnittliche energie dieser druck
kontinents produziert und das sind
gerade einmal 100 watt das ist so viel
leistung wie eine ehemals handelsübliche
glühbirne oder fünf heutige led birnen
liefern
er trägt beim laser ist nur dass die
energie zeitlich und örtlich stark
zugeführt wird und dass das licht von
den metallischen oberfläche unter dem
rost wieder zurück reflektiert wird die
deckschicht wird also von beiden seiten
mit energie bestrahlt wie der laser
trotzdem eine relativ breite fläche ab
wächst kann man übrigens wunderbar
wählen wenn man das handgeführte gerät
schnell über eine oberfläche zieht der
fokuspunkt wird ständig von links nach
rechts geschwenkt und jetzt noch eine
andere eigenschaft des laser zu sehen
das gerät funktioniert nicht nur
getroffen sondern auch mit gummibelag
ölresten und sogar mit lack wer jetzt
allerdings denkt dass er sich ein
solches gerät für den eingerosteten
kindes zu hause kaufen könnte der
fortschritt diese laser sind unglaublich
teuer und für industrielle arbeiten von
unternehmen gedacht da lohnt es sich
wirklich den rost lieber selber
abgesprungen wenn ihr mehr über die
photonik akademie erfahren wollt dann
besucht die website der photonik
forschung
den link dazu findet ihr wie immer unten
in der video beschreibung und außerdem
könnt ihr mir oder dem photonik campus
auf twitter und facebook folgen um
informiert zu werden wenn die studenten
für die photonik akademie 2018
ausgewählt werden
bis es soweit ist empfehle ich euch das
video vom letzten jahr in dem ich ein
nobelpreisträger interviewer guck mal
ich hab von clean acer diese platte hier
geschenkt bekommen auf der einen seite
mit laser eingraviert und auf der
anderen seite mein name gelenkt hatte
schon im intro gewinnen und die klasse
kommt jetzt in meinen job schon oder